welcome to this video playing our fair
hut or something this is Carter no
united arab emirates down hard to tell
those apart likewise at least ok let's
go with them McCutchen French and see
what happens I don't really know this
too well hope for Bishop d to at least I
have some wake idea what to do after
that and now I'm yeah that's 36 and King
evade let's play that I only know that
here there is some idea related to
Bishop to d7 these 76 and Knight to d7
okay
yeah that's also this Bishop takes g6
idea but i think i have not G am I think
I should be able to play Bishop e7
you should be six I can play Jade h5 I
can do g5 this should be a big issue oh
yeah oh my caption is an interesting way
to to play in the in the classical
French it leads to a pawn structure
typical for the win over with the bishop
before but roll f form yeah probably i
should take this opportunity and block
the Kings side I know it doesn't look
too great putting everything on white
squares but the question is should i
take and it probably opens up a file for
him is it a problem if I just develop
first and queen a5 problem I can do that
Queen a five gifts gifts I guess me
counter play on with taking on default I
should try that I don't really think
that Queen f 695 is so dangerous maybe
I'm misjudging this possible
and you know like 35 answer notice
haven't is an idea yeah maybe maybe you
can play 95 evening hmm now deform but
how terrible is it for watch don't know
or just Quincy five
not so yeah let's do this this also
allows Queen f2 and Queenie seven if
necessary and I have a simple attacking
plan on c3 so whoops the eight on
something and done now I can also just
go Queenie's heaven and try to exchange
Queens which is some with the weekend
structure the Queen trade would be a
would be okay but let's just get some
something going on c3 there's also a
nice weak spot to attack
uh-huh Queen F to the night
can play Bishop e2 but looks looks very
weird Jack now come on let's give this
check
take here let's log some very weird far
for white the bishop on e2 doesn't
really help and it's not threatening
much question is do I have some direct
continuation 97 maybe 9725 also going to
see 5 or what or d 4 or something like
that this is probably probably even
stronger I have a 94 94 okay let's do
that intending 95 and Queen c5 I can
always drop back with the tempo on c3
look yeah he simply ignores all my moose
95 this isn't this just like winning III
yard or for threatened or should I just
take for us they take first is probably
easier and now this this is over Queen
III Queen f4
jerkin let's take your first cancer
cannot be bad really quick Kingda 323
mate and king d 193 lice is quite
substantial check yeah i can i can do
that if everything else fails i can
exchange now is it nice lots should be
should be enough jack I was just
thinking that maybe my king is in some
trouble but ok yeah well he resigned I
think I'm around here g4 was was really
really bad yeah computer jumps 2-4 after
that and here takes a night a 5s even
stronger threatening night before but it
was good enough I think yeah thanks for
watching